uh i wanted to play this for you because
this was a lot of fun as well
you know of course georgia tech
two nights ago
um speaking out about the
the male invasion of sports and as we
saw you know protesters came out and
they were very upset
but many of them couldn't actually
explain why they were there what they
were upset about i think this kind of
ties into the whole mass hysteria theme
of this show so campus reform they were
also on the scene and here's another fun
interview with uh with a protester he's
got he's you know he's come out he's got
all the protesters behind him they've
got the trans flag they've got all the
signs
and um can he explain why he's there and
what he's so upset about let's see
tell us why you're out here today i'm
standing for trans rights
do you think there is a biological
difference between men and women
biological
i would stand for lesbian gay
um lgb bisexual and trans community
why are you guys out here yelling
instead of maybe going inside i mean
there's a q a you guys have the
opportunity to go in that mask well it's
a question don't you think that would be
more
productive when it comes to republicans
republicans are more argumentative more
my way of the highway
don't you think this might be my way of
the highway here
[Music]
[Applause]
you could not have scripted any better
that was great he
they were they were literally chanting
in the background hey hey ho ho uh was
it matt walsh has to go or this fascist
has to go whatever it was
they're they're that's what they're
chatting in the background while the guy
in the front claims
that republicans are the ones who are
the it's my way or the highway um
you couldn't
you could have scripted any better that
was great
but of course he you know he couldn't
really explain why he was there i'm here
for trans rights
are men and women different biologically
oh but what do you mean biologically i'm
not even sure i'm a college student i
don't know the word biologically means
so they didn't know why we're there they
were there but this is
again for them it's it's a it's hysteria
they're not they're not they they don't
really know why they're there or what
they're doing
but um
pulling the strings the people who are
encouraging this
you know there's that that's a very
intentional choice
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content